all right before we get into it a word
from our sponsors that's right
our sponsor is that doe-eyed bastard
right there that hopeful son of a [ __ ]
who has no idea the video he's gonna
make in a few short years which is this
video so Bob iger's come out with a book
what's it called I don't know the name
of the book Bob Iger my journey or
something Bob Iger my farts smell like
roses I'm sure it's called that and in
one of these chapters in this book the
chapter again I don't know the name of
the chapter so we'll just call it that
time we but [ __ ] George Lucas and then
made him smile at our faces at Star Wars
Celebration again not called that I'm
making [ __ ] up but this next part I'm
not making up in Bob iger's book Bob
Iger who's a CEO of Disney for those of
you who don't know he's the guy who owns
the Monopoly board he's that kid you
don't want to play with because you're
like you own everything [ __ ] you would
anywhere I'll and I'm screwed boy does
Bob Iger straight-up says George Lucas
felt betrayed by what they did with Star
Wars all right I'm gonna go ahead and
put a link below where you can you can
read the snippets the paragraphs get the
gist basically they were like hey Lucas
alright we're buying this and uh yeah
we'll keep you around as a consultant
which we knew I actually made a joke
about that back in the day when Disney
but I was like oh they're keeping him on
as a consultant yeah they're just gonna
push him to the back with a box of
crayons we're gonna stay over there I
feel bad now as being a dick what I did
back then story goes George Lucas when
he was selling Star Wars to Disney for
4.5 billion dollars in labels like four
to four point five twenty is four
billion is in there he had outlines for
Episode seven eight nine and they were
like sweet George we will take those
into account what he wants us to do and
what we have to do are two very
different things
and then when Lucas found out like wait
a minute you didn't go with my script
ideas Lucas felt betrayed that's what he
says your argument is well this stuff
happens all the time in movies you're
right it does or there are contracts and
handshake agreements and then people who
don't follow through with those
handshake agreements because the
contract says they don't have to the
funny thing is though the fact that Bob
I grieve
has this in his book like whose
brilliant idea was this is it his it
just shows the disconnect between him
and the rest of humanity was it like all
right we need a Star Wars thing to get
people jacked on Star Wars so all right
Bob Iger release your book now where you
kind of look like a dick when it comes
to George Lucas and the deal that'll get
people thinking about Star Wars that's a
dumb PR move if that's what it was in
the end I think it boils down to the
fact that he doesn't think he looks like
a dick and he totally does I feel like
in Bob iger's mind who I can't read I
don't know the guy I don't know his
actual mindset but the fact that he even
released this thing is him going but but
I didn't break the contract so I don't
feel like I don't look like an [ __ ]
right right what the law says
bill Berg has a great bit about that I'm
sick of this yeah that's what the law
says hundred years ago I could beat you
with a [ __ ] mop handle be like that's
what the law says
let's make us right right just because
you can do it because the contract says
doesn't mean you're not an [ __ ] if
you do that thing and George Lucas is no
dummy right like he knew that it was a
handshake agreement that they were they
were under no obligation to use his
stuff I also get that the fact is like
if you don't think Disney if you don't
think they were [ __ ] through this
whole thing if you don't think they're
being complete douche bags if you don't
think they're [ __ ]
then you can't ever think your boss is
being an [ __ ] for anything boss like
or business related that your boss does
legally speaking right here's a scenario
all right it's your anniversary you ask
for your boss to have your anniversary
off and your boss is like promise you
you can have that well you know what
have the weekend off go on that trip
that you've planned with your wife or
husband or whoever and then when the
boss is making the schedule nah you
don't get that weekend off you bought
your tickets everything's ready and plan
to go but you know you got to work is
your boss an [ __ ] yes more of an
[ __ ] than what Disney did with George
Lucas no it's just an anniversary
there'll be another one so if you roll
with Disney you got a roll with any
[ __ ] boss you ever have without
complaint this is like the dick boss
move of dick boss moves but to me it
totally does show the disconnect the
fact that it's just so normal or no just
talking about it like that's a Hollywood
it's not a
Hubb if any high morality Hollywood is
actually they're just they're douchebags
a lot of them because they're snakes
they're sharks they're piranhas and the
loud fish in that one small pond called
Los Angeles called Hollywood they're
what the spear heads of higher morality
online basically it shows that the
mindset of Hollywood is it's not what
you do it's what you say because you can
lie to a guy's face and be like wool the
contract says so like a real piece of
[ __ ] but if we find out you tweeted
anything edge Lord or [ __ ] up 10 years
ago you know words that don't actually
hurt people you will be fired because
that's really harmful stuff all right on
to lying to people what like what and
the word is George Lucas wanted to delve
deeper into meta chlorines and the Wills
of the force you know the quantum level
of the force or at least microbiology
you know which that might have been
shows maybe it would have been [ __ ]
maybe it would have validated
midi-chlorians maybe it wouldn't have
but one thing I know for sure is we
would have at least gotten something
different and at the very least gotten a
cohesive story that had a clear
beginning and a clear end and a path
getting there
like what'swhat's the path now no one
knows and know all the [ __ ] in Episode
nine the Emperor coming back it wasn't
planned no one will ever convince me it
was planned it's just damage control and
again it's just it's damage control
using [ __ ] from the original trilogy to
get people back on board with Star Wars
and sorry that worked with the force
awakens but it's not gonna work now
there were a few ways people process
Disney's Star Wars there were people who
were out the gate we're like not force
awakens just a waste of time it's just a
retread I've always been a force awakens
apologist because I was looking to
understand why they did that we'll come
back to that in a second and then the
last Jedi hit there were people like no
not at all this is [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
there was me like but let me process
thank you fine right mm-hmm
and then time goes on and you're like no
things are not fine and then there are
people who are still like doc it's all
good thanks for fine and what pisses me
off most about this is we all thought
that the last Jedi was the anomaly that
was the big betrayal of care
right but no it wasn't it was the force
awakens from the get-go so it changes
that the context of the force awakens it
changes the context of everything didn't
start with the last Jedi it started with
the force awakens like it's very
inception it was a betrayal to George
Lucas and what he wanted it have been
such a force awakens apologist cuz
they've been like well no I understand
why they did it that way
and it pisses me off because now I look
at me in my review back then and I just
get sad yeah you sit there with your
[ __ ] smile in the end hats off to
Disney for being for the brilliant chess
move that they did because you know that
conversation happens we're totally not
gonna use George Lucas a script fans
will find out one day and they'll be
pissed if they don't just see it on
screen what do we do well sir
we could just have the lead be a strong
female character if anyone criticizes it
they're just sexist [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] mess and we would have gotten a
universe like a universe that we can
connect with that we know how it works
like what what is the what's the galaxy
like in the Disney Star Wars movies
what's it actually like like an original
trilogy we have the Empire that was
simple enough we all knew that it's an
empire and a rebellion the Empire is the
super government that the rebellions
trying to stop in the prequels we had
the Republic it's very clear it's a huge
part of all of it what's the government
like in Disney Star Wars I don't know
what's it like like there was a republic
that was wiped out by this super death
laser from a planet but as I understand
Khorasan wasn't one of the planets that
blew up so is there still Khorasan don't
give me that [ __ ] about one of the books
that explained it I'm sure one of them
had to have by now but I shouldn't have
to ingest the books to understand the
movies that's my point what is what if
you're just going on Disney star wars
movies you feel like the first orders
it's kind of like Isis there's just like
this rabble of terrorists and they're
fighting a smaller rabble of rebels or
resistance because we can't call them
rebels because they'll probably George
Lucas money that's also a huge that yeah
I don't think the Mandalorians actually
Bubba Fett because of the
DeLorean was Boba Fett they there's
probably something saying they George
Lucas some form of merchandise rights
because he created the character of Boba
Fett so yeah I think Disney Star Wars
will make the Mandalorian his own
character because they don't want to pay
George Lucas anything kind of
compromises the whole thing about the
Mandalorian doesn't it
[ __ ] so you have this group of
terrorists the first order and a smaller
group of rebels or resistance and
they're fighting but what are they
fighting for who runs the galaxy doesn't
look like the first order does is there
a bigger government that's like in the
first order and the resistance they're
fighting again and this podunk off ass
planet doesn't really concern us so back
to business legislation like does it
even matter what they're doing it just
kind of feels like it's this no
government wild west
Mad Max ish galaxy slowest car chase
ever so yeah I have my thoughts in the
end all of this boils down to the fact
that regardless of your sentiment of the
prequels and I do think time has
validated the prequels in the eyes of
the fandom anyway you might not like the
prequels I prefer the original trilogy
myself but in the eyes of the fandom as
a whole the prequels have been validated
through time because dialogue aside to
its core that there was something there
I just it all just came at the right
time for me all of this has I rewatched
the prequels I watched Bram Stoker's
Dracula which after watching Bram
Stoker's Dracula it's like it hit me
like a bolt of lightning like oh my god
he was that's what he was trying to do
with Anakin Anakin is Dracula
essentially this legendary war soldier
and then the woman he loves dies and he
just snaps and gives himself over to
being the right hand of the devil
essentially in the end it he's a victim
of his own choices and after seeing Bram
Stoker's Dracula recently I understood I
got it would have liked that to have
happened in episode 2 and episode 3 just
been Vader being a badass wreck and Jedi
but I digress the concept hit me and I
understood it there's no such poetry in
the new Disney Star Wars movies this is
not there and it could have been had
they followed George Lucas's guideline I
mean he's a great visionary right like
his concepts his world building it's
amazing his script writing so you get
someone else to write the script based
off of his ideas they could have had
something special something that would
the test of time in the end I feel like
Disney was just too faced with George
Lucas cuz they wanted to make a quick
buck and they did they made a quick buck
well played but you're dicks for it
doctors who can blame him who can blame
him for selling it who can blame Disney
for [ __ ] them over like that I mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] like me got on camera said
bad George Lucas is pretty well that
yeah Disney's gonna do their own thing
it's gonna be awesome
we paved the way for him we validated
them we we gave them the green light I
can't speak for everybody I feel like I
did though anyhow
George Lucas I'm sorry I mean it I say
things with a smile a lot of times I
can't imagine what that feels like I
can't imagine what it feels like to have
someone smile at your face and tell you
the important thing is to respect these
characters or however Kathleen Kennedy
said it the main thing is to protect
these characters make sure that they
still continue to live in the way that
you created them in the end we're not
gonna follow your outline for that and
they're all gonna die a lot of them are
anyway but hey making way for four new
characters fact is regardless of your
sentiment on George Lucas and his
handling of the prequels or the original
trilogy is constant meddling of the
original trilogy adding [ __ ] here and
there I've always I have my thoughts on
all of that a regardless of all of that
this is the father of Star Wars and he
deserved better that's fair god no it's
dawning on me I just said he deserved
better than four billion dollars it's I
don't know maybe I'm a simple guy you
know like I'm not a corporation I'm not
a corporate guy I'm just me and I lift
my I try to just minimize my life and
live a simple happy life and in the end
integrity matters like keeping your word
to somebody it matters and a lot of
artists out there I've heard the
grievances of artists who don't own
their music it's actually the
corporation that does it's everybody
who's had that hat
to them the common denominator is their
like it feels like in a sense it's it's
your brainchild they own a part of you
maybe with this billions he'll get over
it I just think integrity matters also
important to humor the idea that maybe
this is Bob Iger apologizing to Lucas
like maybe this is his way of doing it I
haven't read the whole book just a the
snippets that have to do with this but
he does say he could have handled this
better so maybe that's his way of saying
sorry George Lucas maybe he called
George Lucas up and has said privately
hey sorry George Lucas you know maybe
that's happened maybe they've broken
bread maybe they're like hey it's cool
we're on beaches and were rich now and
we're gonna be fine but undeniably the
Star Wars saga is that we got under
Disney Star Wars it's not the one that
Lucas planned for us to have alright so
all of this this whole George Lucas
Disney situation infected Bob Iger put
it in a book three months before the new
movies comes out the new Star Wars movie
like it's not gonna just be on people's
minds like when I'm watching the rise of
Skywalker I'm not gonna sit there be
Loggins George Lucas didn't want any of
this [ __ ] he wanted none of this that's
another thing that he would have done
differently that he just totally didn't
want you dicks to do that you dicks
totally did like it's not gonna creep
into our brains somehow what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]